-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching at home.
I just want to say
to all the parents at home
eating your children's
Halloween candy,
you know what
you're doing is wrong.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you can tell
today is November 1st
'cause all the Spirit Halloweens
have gone back
to being abandoned
Sears Outlets.
Let's get to some news.
Guys, the midterm elections
are just one week away.
That's right. In one week,
we'll know who gets the House,
the Senate, and the upper hand
at Thanksgiving.
[ Light laughter ]
You can tell
the midterms are close
when the fundraising e-mails
are in all caps.
"JIMMY, I NEED 10 DOLLARS NOW!"
[ Laughter ]
And get this --
as if the midterms
weren't already crazy enough,
apparently the country
is facing
a paper-ballot shortage.
Right now the MyPillow guy
is yelling at a tree
for rigging the election.
A paper-ballot shortage.
Now on Election Day,
you have to close the curtain
and just yell for
who you're voting for.
Like, "Republican, Republican,
Democrat, Republican!"
[ Light laughter ]
Well, President Biden
is working hard
to give Democrats a final
push before the election.
Starting today, he's appearing
at campaign rallies in Florida,
New Mexico, California,
Pennsylvania, and Maryland.
Yeah, if a jet-lagged
79-year-old
can't rally the Democrats,
nothing can.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah, today,
Biden was in Florida,
which is a tough place
for Democrats.
I mean, right now
one Democrat in Florida
is losing to an alligator
with a mullet.
It's interesting.
Well, this is wild --
I read that Republicans
are expecting
former President Trump
to be indicted
soon after Election Day.
Yeah, it feels like
the political version
of waiting to break up
with someone
until after the holidays.
It's like, "Ah, just..."
Yeah, Trump could be indicted
for the holidays,
which sounds kind of like
a Christmas movie on MSNBC.
Speaking of
the former president,
Supreme Court Chief Justice
John Roberts
just temporarily blocked
Congress
from obtaining years of Trump's
federal income tax returns.
Yep, Trump was so excited,
he started chugging ketchup
like he'd won the Indy 500.
He's like...
Switching gears, now that Elon
Musk has taken over Twitter,
he apparently also wants
to bring back Vine
to compete with TikTok.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like it.
I think it'd be a great idea.
I also think it would be great
if they had a feature
where you could fast-forward
videos to get to the best part.
You know what I'm saying?
For example,
you could skip this part...
Yeah.
And go --
go right to this part.
-Ow!
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
I didn't know the first part
was that fast.
[ Laughter ]
-It snuck up on you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it was actually -- you could --
you could actually
watch the whole video.
[ Laughter ]
That makes no sense.
Let me give you an example here.
You skip this part...
Yeah.
And go right to this part.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's what I want to see. I --
Let's give one more example.
You can skip this part...
Yeah, and go right to this part.
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Flipper!
-Wow.
Guys, get this.
The makers of Ring doorbell
are about to release
their first car alarm.
I'm not sure how helpful it is.
All it does is let you watch
someone steal your car.
You go, "Oh..."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that TV ratings
for this year's World Series
between the Astros and the
Phillies are the best in years.
So, naturally,
a lot of the brands
want to get their message out
to such a big audience.
But I was surprised
at some of this year's
World Series sponsors.
Watch this I saw.
-The MLB World Series
is brought to you by Twitter...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally, in China,
the winner
of a $30-million lottery jackpot
is not telling his family
about it
'cause he doesn't want them
to get lazy.
[ Laughter ]
It's just gonna be weird
on family vacations
when the kids are like, "Why is
dad in first class without us?"
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ The legendary ♪
♪ Hardworkin' ♪
♪♪
-I'm excited. I'm excited. What
a show we have for you tonight.
First of all, she stars in
"Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX November 11th.
That is gonna be
the biggest movie ever.
Lupita Nyong'o is here!
-Yeah!
-Lupita!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, he's the biggest-selling
comedy recording artist
of all time,
and his new movie,
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story,"
is available for free,
exclusively on the Roku channel
this Friday.
Weird Al Yankovic
is on the show.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers
-It's fantastic. It's fantastic.
[ Applause ]
Plus -- Can we zoom in
on this right here?
He is taking his movie,
"Almost Famous," to Broadway,
with "Almost Famous:
The Musical,"
which opens Thursday at
the Bernard B. Jacobs Theatre.
Cameron Crowe is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love "Almost Famous."
I love Cameron Crowe.
We're gonna talk to Cameron,
and then we have a performance
from the cast
of "Almost Famous."
And it's a song --
It's a song that you love.
[ Applause ]
-I'm very excited about this.
I have a new holiday song
I'm releasing,
with me and Dolly Parton,
called "Almost Too Early
for Christmas."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's out Friday, November 4th.
And. so, I talked
about this last night,
I put it on TikTok
with the song
and say it's out on Friday.
And TikTok took it down.
It's illegal.
-What -- Because --
-Because it's not out yet?
-They said --
Yeah, because it's not out.
They said they couldn't
get the rights to...
So now I'm in a lawsuit
with myself.
-Oh, my --
You're suing yourself?
-I'm suing myself. And I'm not
returning my phone calls.
-Really?!
-I'm gonna let me
sweat it out a little bit.
-Oh, wow. Acrimonious.
-Yeah, 'cause I don't know
if I'm ready -- Really?
What, am I gonna listen to me,
make decisions about my music?
-No. F that. F that noise.
-So I don't --
It's a great song.
I can't wait
for people to hear it,
but I guess
it actually is too early.
[ Laughter ]
TikTok told me it actually
is too early for Christmas.
The point of the story is,
if you want to --
if you like it, if you want
to retweet it, you can't.
Not until Friday.
-Friday.
-Friday it's out.
Thank you, Dolly.
And I'm sorry, me.
Guys, speaking of retweeting,
it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we --
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can see them right there.
Yeah.
I love the people acting like
they didn't see the clickers
when they sat down.
They're the only things there.
Yeah, they're right there, yeah.
You can vote for all of them,
by the way.
And you can also vote
for none of them.
Whatever. I just want
you to have a good
time, enjoy yourself.
We're gonna see
the results live.
We have a very expensive
machine we paid like...
-Really?
-...$25 to $30 for.
-Really?!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's an old laptop.
Remember Gateway computers?
-Oh, it's a Gateway?
-Yeah, yeah.
It's an old Gateway laptop,
and that's hooked
into this polling system.
-Yeah. 8 bits.
-But it's real.
Higgins, you have your clicker?
-Got my clicker.
-Roots, clickers?
-Yep, all done.
-Perfect.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
live on the show
during commercial break.
So you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
[ Cheers ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright.
You guys ready for this?
Our first tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
I --
-Come on.
-Yeah, I like it.
I don't know --
I don't quite know
what it means.
But I like it.
Alright.
Thumbs up, thumbs down.
Quest, this is the first time
I've ever seen you
not just say yes to it.
-I'm gonna say yes
'cause I like my job but --
I don't get it.
-You'd rather just say no.
-Well, the votes are in. Let's
see the results on this one.
Whoa. Look at that! Not bad!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-That one's got potential.
That was 138?
-1-3-8.
-1-3-8. Hold on a second.
-[ Higgins squeaking ]
-Alright, here we go.
I don't need -- I don't need
sound effects for the mar--
-[ Higgins squeaking ]
-Alright.
This next one here is...
[ Laughter ]
At that point...
-That's a speaker.
-Yeah.
At that point, it's a bop.
Alright, I feel like
everyone made their decision
on that one pretty quick.
Let's see the results.
-Oh.
-Ooh.
[ Applause ]
-[ Higgins squeaking ]
1-2-4. Not so good.
-No, no, no. Not too good.
Alright.
How about this next one here?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. That's cute.
-Boo!
-Hm. I got a -- Someone booed.
-Yeah. I think they think
it's more cute than funny.
Is that what you're saying?
-Alright.
-Alright. What do you got?
-Let's see the results
on this one.
-Whoa!
-I like it.
-1-4-8. That's the topper.
-1-4-8. That's not bad.
-That's the topper now,
isn't it?
-Yeah, that's the topper. The
first one means nothing to me.
-Yeah.
-Uh, this one --
Oh, I like this one.
Next up, it goes...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
-That's a thinker.
-That's a thinker,
but it's funny.
And, you know what,
if you like comedy...
-Yeah, that's the way to go.
-It's something --
-You couldn't finish the tweet
'cause you fell into a.
-That's -- Well, that's what --
But I'll -- You --
I wouldn't put that
in your mouth --
You were putting
those words in --
-You, co-author of the piece.
Yeah.
-Comedy prop.
-Hole -- Manhole.
You fell right in it.
-Yes.
-With a banana peel.
[ Rim shot ]
-Let's see the results
on that one.
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about!
Yes!
-1-6-3!
-I agree.
I don't know if we're
gonna top that one.
Uh, no,
I don't think we'll top it.
-You think so?
-I don't know.
What do you think, Tariq?
-I think we can
definitely top that one.
I think that one was
low-hanging fruit.
-Low-hanging fruit.
-Oh, "low-hanging fruit."
-Is this the last one?
-Yeah.
-Come on. Like --
-Come on, people.
-I think we can do it, guys.
No matter what it is,
let's make this one...
-Yeah, make this one the winner.
-Like, yeah,
let's make this one the winner.
Like, make it count.
It's November 1st
up in this bitch.
Let's do this.
-You can't do that.
You can't buy the audience.
-What? I'm not buying --
I'm not paying them.
-Make them decide --
They decide on their own.
-What do I look like,
the Tooth Fairy?
I'm not buying the audience.
-Yeah, you're, like, telling
them what to vote for. No.
-Okay, look.
Do what you want to do.
-You're wearing sunglasses.
No one can even see --
-Well, that's why
it was overexaggerated.
-I couldn't even tell if you're
winking or what you were doing.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. This last one is...
"I can always tell
if I'm not gonna like someone
based on how accurately they
pronounce the word 'cruh-SONT.'"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Now you think it's rigged,
no matter what happens.
-No. I don't -- I don't know.
People are laughing
in the audience, but...
-You think they were
browbeaten into laughing?
-What was the other one
that was 148?
Oh, no, 163. What was that one?
Oh. "Fall into a."
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I think "Fall into a."
-Right.
-But that's me, personally.
-Right. You personally.
It's your tweet.
-And then this one is which one?
Cruh-SONT?
-This was how accurately
they say the word cruh-SONT.
-Or -- Or -- Or as Jimmy
would say -- KWAH-SAH.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. What do you think, Higgs?
-I think -- I don't know.
I think this one is not as good,
but it might win.
[ Laughter ]
-He just trying
to cover all bases.
-Yeah.
-Tariq, you think this one's --
Do you agree with Higgins?
-This one's through the roof.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-"Yeah."
Let's see the results.
-Ohh!
-We did it!
We did it! We did it!
-Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
Wow! Oh, my gosh.
They love you. That's why.
-My people, my people.
-I will post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.